[Music]
what's your thought on the matter
deflategate do you think this is
something that patriots intentionally
did you know what I have no idea I know
that it seems that the NFL has been on
this one now for the last few weeks
obviously there's always seems to be
some topic going into Super Bowl week -
what just happens to be it so yes I will
be asked this a thousand times and to be
honest with you I just I kind of chuckle
because I'm just glad it has nothing to
do with us
right did you know a difference between
a legally inflated football and a
slightly under inflated football do you
think you would know the difference you
know throughout the course of the game I
know you because a ball ball will come
up and you don't even think about how it
feels you might program to you know go
through your read throw the ball no
excuses I mean but if we sat here and
just you know kind of grip grip the one
I could probably tell the difference
let's find out okay tell me what you
think of this one just give it a good
feel that's well inflated I would say
well inflated meaning legal I would say
thirteen ounces that is exactly 13 okay
that is exactly
cuz I just you know if I throw that to
one of the Saints fans
[Applause]
[Applause]
right again yeah you can't there are
rights up there those are life I'm gonna
step up yeah those are lights you got to
go low you got to thread that needle
[Applause]
[Music]
let's give that up field let me yes what
do you say at 11
I'm just saying 11 said 11 ounces do you
think that's under-inflated that is
under-inflated by 2 ounces I'm thinking
that is exactly 11 psi okay I was uh I
was a bit thrown off there
yeah can I give it a go
[Laughter]
[Applause]
let's do it here what you just what
you've just demonstrated is it is easier
to throw and catch
yes an under inflated football
you
you